Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Uuuuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuh Ja, hi, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Das-Podcast, UFO-Podcast-Projektes 2023 TM.
Ja, ich glaube, wir müssen mal reden.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns mal alle zusammensetzen.
Jeder nimmt sich einen Stuhl.
Der, der gerade reden will, das lohnt, hin will.
Das ist korrekt.
Ich bin Stefan Tietze. Ja, kommt doch erstmal alle rein, genau.
Genau, Entschuldigung, ich habe jetzt zu früh angefangen. Kommt erstmal rein.
Nehmt euch einen Stuhl da vorne vom Stapel hinunter. Da vorne gibt es Snacks, ich habe gebacken, ich habe gestern noch Zimtschnecken gemacht. Müsst die Stühle unten einmal so kräftig aufklappen, die haben wir alle nochmal zusammengeklappt. Die haken manchmal ein bisschen und wenn am Ende jeder seinen eigenen Stuhl dann wieder zurückstellen kann, dann geht es einfach auch schneller. Merkt euch einfach, welchen Stuhl ihr genommen habt. Da hinten gibt es Kaffee von der Claudia, ich glaube das mit der blauen Kappe war der koffeinfreie, ne? Ja. Sag nochmal, ja, Daumen hoch. Blau ist Koffeinfreie. Ja, also wir reden heute über Maximilian. Genau, also er ist jetzt schon, also Flo und ich unterrichten die Klasse. Genau, wir unterrichten das ganze Kommeilteam. Ja, nicht nur negativ. Nein, das muss man schon sagen. Also er ist ein auffälliger Junge, das muss man sagen. Ja, ein besonderer Junge. Ich sag mal so, die letzten Jahre ist er durch viele Sachen aufgefallen, vor allem war er ein aktives Mitglied dieser Community und ist. Ja, absolut. Er ist nicht mehr wegzudenken. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich im Kriteritum spreche. Er ist aus dem Klassenbild nicht mehr wegzudenken. Jetzt schon mal gar nicht. Er hat sich den Charakter aufgedrückt in gewisser Weise.
Und ja, was macht er denn zu Hause so viel?
Weil hier ist er immer sehr viel, also er dreht sich ganz schnell, zu schnell, wie ich finde.
Er sagt, es ist nicht schnell genug, aber er hat das Gefühl, er müsste sich noch schneller drehen.
Ja, hi, ich bin Marco. Marco, hallo. Marco Wiesmann. Ich bin der Vater von Maximilian. Ah, schön, okay. Gut, dass wir Sie auch mal hier kennenlernen. Ja, genau. In den letzten Jahren war ich in Norwegen. Wo waren Sie da? In Hansgren. Ja, ich sehe schon. Das ist eine kleine Stadt, die ist ein bisschen südlich von Trondheim. Sie haben sich da gut eingelebt? Da habe ich mich eingelebt, genau. Meine Ex-Frau ist hier, die passt auf den Maximilian auf. Ich bin jetzt mal hergekommen, weil ich den Brief bekommen habe. Und dann dachte ich mich, ja gut, irgendwas scheint nicht zu funktionieren in Deutschland. Und dann bin ich zurückgeflogen, habe mir die ersten Flieger genommen. Dann aus Trondheim bin ich zurückgeflogen, habe den Direktflug genommen und bin jetzt hier. Um mal zu hören, was passiert ist, es tut mir sehr leid. Also alle Vorfälle tun mir leid. Können Sie sich vorstellen, warum man sich gerne so schnell dreht? Ja, zum einen möchte ich mir die Frage stellen, wer will sich nicht gerne sehr schnell drehen? Es ist ja ein bisschen disorientierend. Es ist disorientierend, aber da liegt ja auch ein bisschen der Spaß drin. Also ich möchte wirklich ernsthaft von allen Elternteilen hier und von Ihnen beiden jetzt mal hören, wer dreht sich nicht gerne sehr, sehr schnell. Vielleicht kann man ein Handzeichen, vielleicht kann man ein Handzeichen machen? Das weiß ich gar nicht, was nötig ist, das hier abzustimmen, aber okay. Aktuell sind keine Hände oben, keine Hand ist oben. Ja gut, wir diskutieren auch noch darüber, ob ein Handzeichen überhaupt zum Ziel führen. Ich glaube, es ist ganz gut, damit nicht jeder, wollen Sie jetzt jeden einzelnen durchfragen?
Nee, ich würde nur mal so in den Raum diese Frage stellen, einfach mal als rhetorisches Gimmick, ob wir uns nicht alle gerne schnell drehen.
Also ob das für Ihr Argument so gut ist, wenn Sie es direkt als Gimmick von her zeigen.
Ja, ich sehe, woher Sie kommen.
Sie können sich auch gerne hinsetzen, ich weiß gar nicht, warum Sie stehen.
Okay, ja.
Schatz.
In Norwegen macht man das.
Das ist eine alte Tradition aus dem Henskerra-Gebirge.
Aha.
Jetzt fangen sie auch an.
Moment mal.
Es macht Spaß, sich zu drehen und dabei zu rufen.
Sie dreht sich immer schneller.
Er dreht sich immer schneller.
Ich finde, das macht immer Spaß. Er hebt ab. Und er war nie wieder gesehen. Vielen Dank an Maximilian für das Intro. Das kam in der Sprachnachricht einfach dran, kontextlos. Vielleicht war es gar nicht als Intro gemeint, sondern mehr so ein Lob. Vielleicht hat das Handy gedacht, so jetzt mache ich mich an. Also ich weiß nicht, manchmal denkt das Handy auch so, boah, hätte ich das mitgeschnitten, das wäre es gewesen, oder? Denkst du dir manchmal, boah, ich war gerade so fucking lustig, alleine in der Bar, da war niemand das gesehen. Da bin ich immer am lustigsten. Und das Handy denkt sich, jetzt komm, jetzt mal auf eigene Faust. Vor allem das hört ja eh immer mit. Ja, genau, und ich glaube, die werden ja eh irgendwann haben eigenes Bewusstsein und ich glaube, es wird eher so sein, nicht irgendwie Welt erobern, sondern so, du pass auf, als du heute morgen in der Dusche gesungen hast.
Ich habe das mal aufgenommen und habe da mal so einen Rhythmus drunter. Das war ja mit meiner Ex-Freundin Clara. Genau, ja, sehr echt, sehr roh, sehr emotional. Und ich habe da mal so eine Gitarre drunter gelegt. Clara, gestern Abend hätte ich dich fast angerufen, ich war betrunken und hätte es nicht machen sollen. Doch im letzten Moment habe ich mich Gott sei Dank dagegen entschieden. Clara, du fehlst mir sehr. Ich habe das Ganze mal auf Spotify hochgeladen. Oh mein Gott, das ist mir mega unangenehm. Und das hat jetzt schon 20.000 Views. Ja, das ist unglaublich. Aber wenn Franzi erfährt, dass ich immer noch über Clara singe. Naja, das ist eine Kunstfigur oder so. Ja, es ist einfach der Name meiner Ex-Freunde. Ich sage auch ihren Nachnamen sogar in Stoffe zwei. Stefan, ich habe doch Ex-Site einen Spitznamen genommen als Musikertitel, als Pseudonym.
As Money? As Money, ja. Unsympathisch. Du bist als As Money. Der emotionale, einfühlsame As Money. Bist du jetzt auf Spotify. Du bist auf Eins der Besten, nein, Neuerscheinungen. Eins? As Money, du bist auf Eins der Newcomer. Ich habe da mal was für dich angerührt. Okay, jetzt gefällt es. Aber die Handys hören ja eh die an das Set mit. Ja, Beweis, Beweis eins, B1, wenn du sagst Siri oder Alexa, reagieren sie ja. Heißt, sie müssen ja die ganze Zeit zuhören.
Ah, das ist das alte Paradoxon, das Luftballon-Paradoxon. Das ist so ein Paradoxon? Ich habe mal das Paradoxon aufgestellt, angenommen du schläfst und jemand sagt, fünf und du wachst auf. Weiss, kannst du dann sagen, welche... Was machen Sie in meiner Wohnung? Gut, das wäre... Nachdem man das geklärt hat. Was machen Sie in meiner Wohnung? Nachdem man das geklärt hat. Was? Na ja, aber dann... Haben Sie gerade fünf gerufen? Ah, Sie wissen also fünf? Sie wissen fünf. Ich habe gerade fünf gerufen. Sie haben also die fünf verstanden. Können Sie Ihre... Sie reden mitten in der Nacht, Sie reden so laut. Dann gehe ich. Entschuldigung, dann gehe ich. Sie reden so laut. Okay, ich bin schon raus. Ich bin schon, ich nehme meinen Rucksack, ich nehme meinen Rucksack. Okay, wenn das zu laut ist. Okay, dann gehe ich. Gott sei. Und das meinst du jetzt mit, wenn Siri Siri sagt, kannst du das dann mitnehmen? Ich bin die Vorstellung so gut angenommen, man schläft nebeneinander mit der Partnerin, Langzeitfreund, was auch immer, und man kann nachts nicht schlafen, man merkt irgendwie, die Partnerin oder so schläft auch nicht und dann, man macht nicht die Nachtstimme, sondern dann leitet voller Lautstärke, ach, kannst du auch nicht schlafen? Das wäre so fucking funny, weil du kannst nachts, du kannst nachts, kannst du nicht, du musst ja nicht mal laut reden, aber so, ah, kannst du auch nicht schlafen. Das ist ein ganz normaler Lautstärke. Es wäre so weird. Ohrenbetäubend laut. Ja, es klingt, weil nachts die Ohren sind ja genauso wie Augen, nicht an Licht und Lauterke gewöhnt, sondern man muss nachts immer sagen, ah, kannst du auch nicht schlafen, nein. Dabei ist niemand in der Wohnung, den man damit wecken könnte, man ist zu zweit in der Wohnung, Nachbarn, gute Wände isolieren, alle schallt zum Nachbarn, man kann aber nicht sagen, ah, na, Vollmond. Auch nicht mit der Stimmung, das ist so null müde einfach so. Ah, toll, Vollmond wieder, danke, drei Uhr nachts. Ah ja, da fällt mir ein, gestern hat der Mirko gesagt, was ganz komisches zu mir gesagt, der Kollege, sowas, mitten in der Nacht. Ach ja, das stimmt. So Themen anfangen, ja das stimmt, das kann man nicht machen. Aber hat doch jeder schon mal so so kleine persönliche Experimente gemacht, oder? Vier. Also mal so zu gucken, ob man Leute beeinflussen kann im Schlaf oder. Ich habe dir schon mal gesagt, Beziehungen sind kein Sozialexperiment. Naja, es ist nun mal eine Art von ... Also dann hat man mal was zur Verfügung so. So ein Versuchsobjekt. Also jeder hat doch in der Beziehung schon mal versucht zu konditionieren. Frauen sind keine Versuchsobjekte. Ja, aber auch eher zu deren Wohl.
Also dass man dann immer mal,
wenn, also klassische pavlovische Konditionierung,
oder hat doch schon jeder gemacht.
Ja, das hat die ja schon mal gemacht.
Oder hat doch wirklich schon mal jeder gemacht.
Dass wenn irgendwas Positives passiert,
dass man dann zufällig ein Lied anmacht
und dann, wenn es der Person schlecht geht,
macht man wieder Cotton Eye Joe an.
Ich konditioniere alle Leute in meinem Umfeld darauf, dass wenn sie einen Fehler zugeben, gebe ich denen was. Da sind immer so ein paar Smarties dabei. So lose Smarties. Nee, vom Streichelzoo, das Essen, was man im Zoo ziehen kann. Genau, in dieser Tüte. Und oft werden die ganz nervöser mit dem Zein. Ja, gerne. Pfote, Pfote. Also fein, ja fein. Danke, danke. Und dann, wenn die Leute, das machen sehr wenig Menschen, ah, da habe ich falsch gelegen, sorry Stefan, du hattest wie immer recht. Ich lag falsch. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Und dann kriegen sie von mir, dann gebe ich denen das Essen aus. Oder ich gebe denen eine Cola in die Hand. Oder ich drücke denen so ein M&M in die Backentasche. Nein, weiß ich nicht. Ich wollte mal gerade gähnt die Situation nutzen und einfach mal schön hinten rein. So richtig schön an die Innenwand der Wange, einfach so richtig schön dran drücken. Ungekaut damit, ungekaut. Nee, verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe, was du meinst. Das habe ich nie gemacht, aber ich finde es cool, glaube ich. Es gibt auch die andere Technik, dass man erst was gibt und der andere dann schlechtes Gewissen hat und man dann nach dem Gefallen fragt. Ah ja. Also du kriegst erst so, oh Stefan, ich habe dir heute eine Flasche Spezi mitgebracht.
Okay, was ist falsch gelaufen? Wofür brauchst du mich?
Gar nichts, gar nichts.
Du bringst mir nie eine Flasche Spezi mit.
Nein, einfach nur, ich war beim Kiosk und dachte, ich bring dir auch eine mit.
Okay, danke schön, ja cool, gern.
Wir müssten aber auch mal irgendwie das Büro mal wieder aufräumen, oder?
Hast du am Wochenende Zeit?
Ja, ich habe Zeit. Danke dir. Ja, danke dir, super, perfekt, vielen Dank. Ich mache alles, was du sagst. Ja, das ist super. Und wenn du den ganzen Müll von den Verpackungen vielleicht noch rausbringen könntest. Ja, ich bring den Müll raus. Perfekt, super, und der Mülleimer, ne? Mülleimer wird ertauscht. Und kannst du vielleicht mal die Kabel enthält, dann sieht hier unten alles auch schon wieder aus wie Sau. Alles klar. Gut, tschüss.
Ciao.
Ja, so ein bisschen wie die Macht, ne? Ich stelle mir immer vor, dass man dann so im Raum sitzt und so, dann nach fünf Minuten ist der Effekt weg, der Zauber ist weg und dann so, was mache ich hier? Hä? Ja, so. Ja, genau, wie bei einem Albtraum. Und dann, was mache ich, warum habe ich Kabel, warum habe ich zerknudelte Kabel in den Hand? Was ist das, was ist das, Schlangen! Okay, man hat auch alles andere vergessen, okay? Aber wie ist das, also du bist ja wieder zurück auf dem Star Wars Train, du bist wieder aufgesprungen auf den Speeder. Und wie ist das denn, wenn jetzt Obi-Wan Kenobi sagt, das sind nicht die Druiden, die ihr sucht, und der Stormtrooper geht weg, alles klar. Gibt es dann den Punkt, wo dieser Effekt wieder aufhört und er sagt, ja, Moment mal, das waren die Druiden, die wir suchen. Oder zehn Jahre später hat er dann immer noch diesen Effekt und sagt bei allen Dingen, wie Frau Frau sagt, sag mal, ist das nicht der Droide, den wir suchen?
Nein, nein.
Nee, das ist doch weggelaufen, das ist doch der Droide, den wir suchen. Nee, das war ein anderer, das war ein anderer.
Und er hat immer noch dieses, das ist nicht der Droide, den wir suchen.
Das war ein anderer, ja, es ist schwierig. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Schatz, ich hab das Gefühl, du willst Bello gar nicht zurückhaben, unseren kleinen Hilfstruiden.
Das sind nicht die Droiden, die wir suchen.
Nee, wie gesagt, ich rede da noch von einem, ich weiß nicht, warumstruiden. Das sind nicht die Droiden, die wir suchen. Wie gesagt, ich rede da noch von einem. Ich weiß nicht, warum man sagt.
Das sind nicht
die Droiden,
die wir suchen. Ja, das sagst du
häufig. Auch im Schlaf sagst du das manchmal.
Alles gut.
Sag ich das wirklich oft. Aber was ist denn mit
Doktor Weissmann, der
Therapeut, hast du mit dem darüber gesprochen,
was du für so eine Droiden... Dass es nicht der Therapeut, den ich suche.
Oh, okay.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ist es geregelt, dass es irgendwann wieder aufhört, oder ist es dauerhaft, für immer einfach? Liegt es nicht an der Geschwindigkeit, mit der er die Zeigefinger und Mittelfinger über die Augen wischt? Ah ja, wie so ein Weckswipen, ne? Genau. Und wenn das sehr langsam ist, dann dauert es lang, und wenn es kurz ist, dann geht es zu kurz. Ich finde auch geil, dass in Star Wars ohne jetzt wieder in Star Wars einzutauchen, es mehr Figuren gibt, bei denen dieser Trick nicht funktioniert, als Figuren, bei denen es funktioniert. Ich glaube, man sieht es ein paar Mal. Das macht den Trick umso schöner. Man sieht es ein paar Mal und dann natürlich Watto kann nicht beeinflusst werden auf Tatooine und dann, glaube ich, dieser Jenga-Gang, dieser Jenga-Gangang kann auch nicht beeinflusst werden, Gangans können auch nicht beeinflusst werden. Das heisst, es ist eine extrem spezifische Kraft, aber es ist natürlich auch blöd, du bist Jedi, dann gehst du ins Universum raus und merkst, deine Kräfte funktionieren bei den allermeisten Spezies einfach nicht. Und denkst dir, was für ein Quatsch, hab ich eigentlich gelernt für einen Unsinn, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Und es gibt Schusswaffen? Moment mal, was, ihr könnt über Distanz kämpfen? Oh nee!
Oh nein, hab ich mich verskillt. Hab ich mich verskillt. Ja, du hast schon recht, aber ich finde, das macht es umso besser, weil es ist nicht so eine Kraft, die überall inflationell eingesetzt wird, sondern man freut sich umso mehr, wenn es klappt, denkt man wieder, oh yes, geil. Weil es ist ein Rieschenkro, Wenn du als Jedi jemandem gegenüber sitzt und du bist ja nicht sicher ... Du kannst dich zum Affen machen beim Date. Schlaf mit mir und sie sagt, okay, das war's. Okay. Ui, das auch nicht. Da kam auch viel raus. Dunkle Seite der Jedi. Nee, das war ja eigentlich das Ende des Jedi-Rats. Nein, wirklich, Obi-Wan. Nein, nein, nicht Obi-Wan, aber es kam viel raus über die Leute.
Sagt nicht Yoda.
Sagt nicht, nein, sagt nicht Yoda. Yoda hat ein paar Padawaner.
Nicht mit, nein, nicht die Jünglinge.
Gott.
Yoda hat ein paar Jünglinge.
Nein, nein, ich dachte, er war einer von den guten.
Nein, mit den Zauberkräften, sagt man ja.
Die Zauberkraft, hätte man auf Deutsch auch einfach übersetzen können. Die Zauberkraft. Möge die Zauberkraft mit dir sein. Wischi wischi Zauberkraft. Aber heute, George Lucas lebt in einer Ranch. Skywalker Ranch. Wo ich mir denke, ab welchem Punkt ist eine Ranch eine Ranch? Also angenommen, ich bin jetzt, sag ich mal, ähnlich erfolgreich wie George Lucas.
Sagen wir mal, so.
Das kann ich nicht so.
Es ist ein Stretch für mich.
Du kannst dir die Fantasie, du kannst dich doch hineinversissen.
Nee, lustigerweise, da hat es jetzt genau aufgehört.
Das ist genau die Grenze deiner Fantasie.
Das ist die Grenze meines Sandkastenprinzips eines Fantasie.
Ja, da ist es vorbei.
Ja, aber okay, sagen wir mal, ich.
Ab wann, also. Ab wann ist eine Ranch? Ab wird es eine Ranch, wenn man sie einfach Ranch benennt? Oder muss man da gewisse Parameter ... Also zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst Villa. Ist eine Villa streng architektonisch definiert? Oder haben Leute einfach angefangen zu sagen ... Unangenehm.
Ich habe nicht gewohnt, sondern sie sind in die Villa gezogen und so.
Oh, krass, ja, okay.
Und dann kommst du da hinten und dann so ... Streng genommen ist das ein Bungalow.
Nein, Entschuldigung, ich habe nachgeschaut.
Und zwar eine Villa ist es, wenn man zwei oder mehr Schlafzimmer hat.
Und wir haben ja in der Garage ...
Das ist eine Doppelhaushälfte.
Aber Tess, tut mir leid, ich bin kein Architekt, ich habe die Regel nicht gemacht. Das ist nur mal die Definition. Du gehst ja raus und sagst, dass du eine Villa eingezogen bist. Ja, aber streng architektonisch ist es eine Villa. Was soll ich denn sagen? Soll ich jetzt dir ein falsches Bild malen oder so? Das ist auch keine Limousine, das ist ein Fiat Panda. Dann kommen wir Leute an und sagen, schönes Haus. Technisch gesehen, Entschuldigung, danke, technisch gesehen ist es eine Villa. Technisch gesehen ist es eigentlich eine Dacia. Also wirklich. Das ist ein Auto. Nee, aber ja, das ist schwierig. Also Abann. Ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen außerhalb von Körnig mir diese Ranch zugelegt. Krass, wirklich? Komm da einfach mal rum. Okay, gerne. Ja, hier, ich hole mal, hier ist das Eingangstor. Stefan, das ist ein Wohnwagen. Ja, das ist ein Wohnwagen. Keine Facts. Aber ich weiß nicht, ab einem gewissen Punkt muss jemand irgendwann mal gesagt haben, das ist eine Villa. Oder ist Villa einfach nur krasses Haus, also ist da schon dieses Krass mit drin? Ja, ich finde es auch merkwürdig. Also ich würde auch niemals selber betiteln. Also ich würde immer versuchen zu understaten mit allem, eh. Aber du würdest schon erwarten, dass wenn du jetzt, sag ich mal, deine Leute einlädst in deine, du sagst Haus, du sagst Bude, ich sag Bude in ein riesiges Herrenhaus und die
Leute sagen, wow, krasse Schuppen, krasser Schuppen.
Ähm, krasse, dass ich das jetzt sagen muss, aber es ist kein Schuppen, Schuppen ist, also ich mir jetzt,
ein Bretterverschlag.
Nein, nein, nein, krasse Bude, krasse Absteige hier.
Ähm, nochmal zurück zu dem, was du, Absteige hast du gerade gesagt, das finde ich jetzt auch, also, Absteige ist architektonisch gesehen, Laminat. Mit der Spätgotik ist das ja eigentlich zu Ende gegangen, also jetzt rein, also wenn wir uns den Zeitstrahl mal vorstellen. Fun Fact, da können wir ein bisschen Absteige, aber gut, architektonisch gesehen, nur rein mit der Got. Egal. Das hier ist eher, mehr so nett.
Du kannst den ganzen Abend nicht entspannen, bis jemand das erste Mal sagt Villa und dann mal so.
Dein Finger ist komplett blutig.
Du hast die ganzen Hautschichten einzeln runtergezogen. Soll ich euch nochmal rumführen? Habt ihr nochmal Lust?
Hast du die Fingernagel gerade abgerissen?
Nein, nein, nein. Soll ich euch nochmal rumführen? Du hast doch schon zwei Roomtours gegeben in dieser Absteige. Jetzt mal ohne Witz. Wie fest kann man am Fingernagel ziehen, ohne dass er ab... Also, wenn jemand lange Finger... Nein, also zum Beispiel, wenn jemand lange Fingernagel hat, denke ich immer so... Also kann man... Also merkt man, oh, jetzt gleich geht's. Oder ist es dann zu spät? Und man unterschätzt. Kann man selber, glaube ich, nicht. Ist es wie so ein Ding, dass man sich nicht den Finger abbeissen kann? Man kann sich nicht, ist das ein Ding? Also ich glaube, rein von der Kraft her könnte man sich den Finger abbeissen. Aber so wie ich es gehört habe, Urban Legend-mäßig, lässt das Gehirn das einfach nicht zu. Das geht einfach nicht. Das logge ich als Antwort für die Fingernagel-Werung.
Aber der Fingernagel ist ja technisch gesehen kein Teil des Körpers.
Fingernagel ist ja wie Kleidung des Körpers.
Leute, Leute, Leute, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, nicht so, langsam, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell, du leihenz mir weg. Drück auf die Bremse, ich hab einen Bremsweg, ich hab einen gewissen Bremsweg, Stefan.
Komm zu mir.
Ich hab einen gewissen Bremsweg, ich hab einen Gesprächsbremsweg.
So, jetzt, okay, bitte.
Also, ich glaube, das ist schon schränkt genommen ein Teil des Körpers. Haare auch. Wir haben jetzt wirklich wieder so eine Definitionsgeschichte. Ist der Hotdog ein Sandwich? Ist Bullshit machen? Ja, da haben wir uns geschnitten. Da haben wir uns doch verzankt. Wir haben zwei Wochen nicht miteinander gesprochen. Ja, wir haben euch gesagt, wir werden im Urlaub. Wir haben gesagt, wir feiern Weihnachten. Ja, genau. Turns out, wir haben uns einfach nur doll verzankt. Ja, das stimmt. Aber wir haben uns wieder vertragen. Aber nein, Fingernagel ist kein Teil des Körpers, wir müssen da nicht drüber reden. Aber ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, vor allem ist es leichter, nach oben oder in die Richtung des Fingers zu ziehen?
Ich will gar nichts drüber nachdenken.
Da habe ich das Problem, was du hast mit den Augen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Sorry, ich will jetzt auch niemanden ekeln.
Weil ich hatte mal eine traumatische Geschichte beim Fingernagel.
Mir wurde nämlich mal die Tür zugeschlagen, während mein Finger dazwischen war. Und dann hat er genau den Fingernagel in der Mitte durchhalbiert und der hing dann noch so dran. Und das war so eklig und kacke und schlimm und schmerzhaft. So steck mir mit einem Schildkrötenbäuche vor. Das, was unter dem Fingernagel ist, verletzbar. So dieses, du schämst dich auch so ein bisschen, so. Ich bin nackt, ich habe nichts an.
Hallo. Don't look at my bruises. Hi. Ja. Jetzt so, ja. Hi, ich bin Fingernagel-Unterseite. Jetzt habe ich nichts mehr an. So gar nicht vorbereitet. Oh, ja, ich komme gleich. Oh, äh, ich komme gleich. Sorry. Ihr habt gesagt, hier kommt niemand. Ihr habt gesagt, hier kommt nie jemand. Fuck, fuck, hier ist nichts aufgeräumt. Auch mit so Augen, die noch nie Licht gesehen haben. Die dann so ganz klein ins Licht blinzeln. Mutter, Mutter, Mutter, bist du zurückgekehrt? Okay, der Charakter wieder. Wobei, das wäre doch mal eine Serie. Die Fingernägel-Unterseite. Ja. Fingernägel-Unterseite 1a. So eine schöne Wohngemeinschaft. 1a-Final. Ja. Unterstrich waff. Also reißt euch mal die Fingernägel raus und schreibt uns, schickt bitte keine Bilder, auf jeden Fall, und das ist gut. Ja, ich muss mich entschuldigen für letzte Folge. Die das Podcast-Ufo, Entschuldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung. Sorry, sorry. Ich habe Unwahrheiten erzählt, mal wieder, aber also es, naja, die Gefängnisse in Berlin quälen nicht über mit Menschen. Aber noch mal, ich habe es, glaube ich, ein paar Mal erwähnt, aber hört auf, euch aufs Podcast-Ufo zu beziehen, wenn ihr irgendwelche politischen Diskussionen führt oder auf so einer Party abhängt und so. Und dann geht es darum, irgendwie, ah, politisch und das, was, was gerade los. Bezieht euch nicht auf uns. Warum solltet ihr euch auf uns beziehen? Wir wissen nicht so viel, wir machen Quatsch. Wir wollen Anstoss zur eigenen Recherche sein. Eigene Recherche. Wir wollen Anstoss zur eigenen Recherche sein. Ihr seid selbstständige Menschen und was wir hier machen, das ist eigentlich nur so, wieso, ihr seid auf der Schrauk und wir schubsen euch so an. Steht hier und schubs dich an und sag, flieg mal, flieg. Flieg und wenn ihr auf dem Mond fallen müsst ihr euch auch ein bisschen besser festhalten, weil wir haben uns aber nichts zu tun. Wir sind nur der Hausmeister, wir machen nur die Tür auf, aber ihr müsst selber schauen, wo ihr da reingeht.
Okay.
Näch?
Ich wollte nur zwei Mathies-Filets.
Wir haben... Ich wollte nur zwei...
Hör mir...
Fass mich nicht an, hör mir mal zu, Mensch.
Ich bin nicht angefasst.
Du bist doch...
Du kannst doch selber nachdenken.
Du hast doch was in der Rübe.
Du kannst doch selber, hör doch nicht auf, wie ein Alten Rohde halt.
Hör doch nicht auf, wie ein Alten Rohde.
Wie gesagt, zwei mal fünfhundert Gramm.
Und hab dich fünfmal, fünfmal, hab ich dir schon gesagt Und du, immer wieder hast du das Gleiche gesagt. Hundert. Fünf. Was hat der? Wer hat gerade fünf gesagt? Also das als unser Statement hört nicht auf uns, sondern falls ihr euch denkt, interessantes Thema, lieber noch mal selber nachrecherchieren, lieber noch mal selber nachrecherchieren, lieber noch mal selber nachrecherchieren, so lehnen wir die Tonleiter, lieber noch mal selber recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst und auf Dänisch, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch mal selbst recherchieren, lieber noch, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Wie gesagt, schaut noch mal. Das steht noch mal selber nach. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Dann habe ich aber viele positive Nachrichten bekommen über die VHS-Geschichte. Ich habe VHS digitalisieren lassen, habe den Domino Day wiedergefunden, alle schreiben Domino Day! wegen des Domino Days. Das war nämlich eine geile Veranstaltung,
gab so nicht mehr. Jedes Jahr
haben die sich auch gestritten mit dieser japanischen Variante,
weil Japaner, und ich glaube,
die waren keine Show. In Japan,
das waren einfach Leute, die dieses Guinness World Record
Die Stadt abgebrannt,
da war alles umgestürzt und umgefallen einfach.
Das war Godzilla. Das war
ernst. Domino.
So heißt die Stadt. Domino. Domino. Domino. Ist umgekehrt. Und kann gut sein. Du machst dich hier lustig, wie mit wackelndem Bauch, schallendem Lachen sitzt du hier vor, wie es kann gut sein. Also Domino. Eines Tages alle Wolkenkratzer. Ich meine jetzt mal komplett mal ohne Witz. Als Architekt. Angenommen, du bist Architekt in New York oder so und du baust einen neuen Wolkenkratzer, musst du dir, also New York ist eigentlich eine blöde Stadt. Blödes Beispiel. So eine blöde Stadt. Frankfurt oder so. Und da baust du einen neuen Wolkenkratzer und dann sagst du, ja, Moment mal, aber da steht ein Wolkenkratzer in Reichweite. Was passiert denn, wenn der in mich reinfällt? Das muss man doch bedenken, dass da nicht irgendwie, da einmal plötzlich ganz Frankfurt so dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumst so, ja, welcher, welcher hat es denn ausgelöst, welcher Wolkenplatz? Es war, es war ihre grosse KFC-Zentrale. Fuck. Mit dem Kernel ganz oben drauf. Der Kernel ist dann ins Commerzbankbilden. Der Kopf des Körmels ist in die Commerzbank, die wiederum in die Deutsche Bank und die Kotz des Körmels ist in... BNB Paribas ist dann direkt runtergestürzt auf den Hauptbahnhof. Okay, aber sind Menschen … Ist auch nur ein Mensch zu schade? Oh ja, einige, ja, ja. Unter dem heissen Fett sind viele Menschen goldknusprig. Okay, aber hat es noch jemanden gefreut, dass der ganze Kernel voller Chicken Wings war? Hat es irgendwen gefreut? Nein, nein, nein, das ist alles verbrannt. Wirkt sich nicht strafmilitend aus. Sie haben nebenbei den Weltrekord für den grössten Domino-Effekt abgeschlossen, aber das ist ja jetzt auch egal. Heute Nachmittag wird dann der Vertreter vom Guinness-Buch der Rekorde hier ankommen, aber naja. Es ist natürlich jetzt schwierig, dich darüber zu freuen, wenn so viele Menschen gestorben sind. Nein, das ist kein Grund zur Freude. Aber kriege ich dann eine Urkunde? Trotzdem sei die Frage erlaubt, kriege ich denn eine Urkunde? Es wird ein Foto gemacht und sie kriegen eine Urkunde und in der 2024er Ausgabe. Das ist alles vor dem Hintergrund, dass so viele Menschen dann doch umgekommen sind. Schrecklich, furchtbar. Eine schreckliche, schreckliche Tragödie. Wirkt vielleicht wie eine unpassende Phase der Frage. Aber kann ich mich vorher noch mal umziehen für das Foto der Urkunde? Also er meinte, er ist um 14 Uhr hier, da hätten sie noch mal. Aber jetzt müssen wir erst mal gucken, dass die ganzen verschütteten Menschen gerettet werden. Trotzdem wäre meine Frage, gibt es da ein Dresscode für dieses Foto? Ich kann Ihnen ein paar Bilder raussuchen von anderen. Sacko und Sh oder ist es eher so ein Sakko? Schauen Sie mal, der hier vom grössten Minenunglück der Welt. Der hat den weissen Anzug an. Ich meine auch vor dem Hintergrund, dass auch da viele, alle Chilenen umgekommen sind. Ganz schreckliche, ganz schreckliche Tragödie. Aber der hat sich jetzt keine Mühe gegeben mit seinem Outfit. Das ist ja trotzdem gestattet, der Kommentar, oder? Naja, das sieht schon ganz ordentlich aus, mit Manschettenknöpfen. Der hat sich noch schicke gemacht. Ist ja egal. Nee, ist ja völlig egal. Aber ihr Gebäude hat den Anstoss gegeben, deswegen kriegen sie den... Aber kriege ich dann alle Bilder, die der Fotograf macht und kann er selber noch abnehmen? Ich weiß, es Fotograf mit dabei, ja, ich weiß nicht, also können wir mal... Nicht, dass der dann irgendwie entscheidet, dass sich dann ein anderes... Der ist ja auch nicht so schön. Ist jetzt vor dem Hintergrund dieser grauenvollen Tragödie, egal, ich glaube aber, dass... Wissen Sie, ob der Architekturpreis für das Gebäude wieder weggenommen wird, wenn es einen Dominoeffekt, einen sogenannten Dominoeffekt auslöst? Oder behalte ich den... und der Architekturpreis für das Gebäude wieder weggenommen wird, wenn es einen sogenannten Dominoeffekt auslöst? Oder behalte ich den?
Nun, der Architekturpreis war leider im Gebäude und der ist noch nicht gefunden worden. Fuck! Die Feuerwehr hat sich entschlossen, erst nach den Menschen zu suchen. Ja, klar, das verstehe ich. Nur wenn sie halt schon mal, wenn ihnen auffällt, dass das Level, die Ebene, das Stockwerk, in dem die Menschen finden.
Es sind so viele Menschen, die noch.
Ja, nur wenn sie da schon mal sind, dann kann man auch kurz danach suchen. Ich meine, das kostet dann auch nicht so viel Zeit.
Da waren auch ganz viele Mitarbeiter, da waren auch noch der komplette.
And scene. Endscene. Die Szene ist vorbei. Diese Szene hat keine Pointe, weil es... Sie fällt um und dahinter steht nichts mehr. So wie jeder... Letzte Domino-Stein. Wie endet eigentlich ein Domino-Day? Das habe ich nie mitbekommen. Also
gibt es dann wirklich, also ich fände es geil, wenn sich das dann
nach diesen riesigen Teppichen noch mal so
auf eine Linie zurück reduziert
und am Ende dann wirklich so ein
Stein so plopp einfach so umfällt
und es geht einfach nicht weiter. Ich habe wie so
Fiebertraumartig gerade so eine Erinnerung,
dass es immer grösser wurde, aber am Ende waren es richtig
große Steine und der hat
dann wie so ein Feuerwerk
noch mal so ausgelöst.
Aber ich fand es immer größer wurde, aber am Ende waren es richtig große Steine. Und der hat dann wie so ein Feuerwerk nochmal so ausgelöst. Aber ich fand immer lame, dass es so Sicherheitslinien gab. Das ist doch lame. Ja, aber die Live-Übertragung will ich mal sehen, wenn da so 50.000 Leute arbeiten da. Und dann hört es einfach auf nach zehn Minuten bei Jeffrey. Nach zwei Minuten fällt es um und vor allem die ganze Halle steht ja noch. Aber es ist trotzdem missglückt. Und Jeffrey steht dann da. Und dann haben die aber noch alle Kameras und dann gehen die so hin und hauen mit dem Fuss um so die Steine einfach zwischendrin. Oder fangen sie an abzubauen. Fangen alle an abzubauen, ohne dass sie umgefallen sind. Ja, wieder zurück in die Kiste. Gut, ja, dann, ich mache nur die grünen, ich mache die blauen. Okay, aber das zeigt man dann viereinhalb Stunden lang, wie die alles wieder einsammeln. Und die Kommentatoren kommentieren sich im Kopf und Kragen, weil sie wissen nicht mehr. Und jetzt sammelt er die schwarzen Steine an, zwölf in einer Hand. Das hätte hier den Taj Mahal ergeben, Kulturhauptstadt des Jahres. Genau, eines der modernen Weltwunder. 2000. Ursprünglich gebaut als Geschenk für die Ehefrau des Sultans. Hier sehen wir ihn noch komplett intakt. Genau, hier sehen wir gerade das Team, baut ihn ab. Ah, jetzt kommt die Schubkarre. Insgesamt sind 20.000 Mitarbeiter hier bedrohtig gewesen, das aufzubauen. Schubkarre kommt. Und hier kommt es rein. Wir haben gesagt, zwölf Steine pro Hand. Das heisst, für diese 84 Millionen Steine insgesamt, das sind eine Menge Hände. Es war immer die Sicherheitslinien, gab es immer, hat mich auch immer genervt, weil es war so ein Safety Net für eine Sendung, die so grandios hätte schiefgehen können, was natürlich auch cool gewesen wäre. Aber was ich lustig finde, das ist der japanischen Sicht, ich glaube nicht wirklich, es war keine Show da, sondern einfach so ein Privatmann, der dann immer den Weltrekord gebrochen hat und der sich immer gewundert hat, dass jedes Jahr die Holländer unter der Leitung von Linda Demol ihn spezifisch, ihm spezifisch den Weltrekord wieder weggenommen haben.
Es war so ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Restrend zwischen dem Domino Day, dieser europaweiten Eurovision-Sendung und fucking Japan, Mr. Jakamoto, der sich überlegt hat, nee komm, was machen die denn da jedes Jahr? Holland vs. Mr. Jakamoto. Es ist insane Unglaublich. Wirklich so, European Broadcast Union gegen diesen einen lonely Soldier, der das versucht, einfach jedes Jahr aufzubauen. Aber hat der dann auch so krasse Bilder gemacht oder einfach nur Masse? Nee, der hat nur einfach nur ... Ja, das sind zwölf Millionen einfach in einem riesigen zu umgefallen. Man muss sich vorstellen, es ging, er hat nur die Breite gebaut. Du stößt es an und dann geht es erst lange in so ein Ding und dann ist es einfach nur sehr breit und alles fällt immer um. Und dieses Geräusch konnte man bis hierhin messen mit einem Seismografen. Das war einfach nur so ein Bumm, noch so in Oklahoma so bei einem Seismografen. Was war das? Was war das? What was it? Haben wir heute irgendwelche Meldungen bei ihm bekommen? Moment mal hier. Ah, ach so, es war einfach mit dem Jakomoto wieder. Ach, das ist Jakomoto. Er ist hier wieder im Dezember. Das ist jedes Jahr, ne? Ja, er hat wieder gewonnen, ja. Die Holländer haben wieder das Nachsehen. Ich bin mal gespannt. Nächstes Jahr zum Domino Day! Perfekter Jingle auch, oder?
Einfach nur, ähm,
also ich hab jetzt mal einen Vorschlag für den Jingle
für Domino Day. Ja, wir sind gespannt, wir sind gespannt.
Wir dachten an so einen kleinen Song. Genau, genau.
Ich dachte,
einfach, simpel,
lass uns einfach den Namen der
Sendung energisch rufen.
Wir hatten ja, wie gesagt, im Briefing stand ja auch einen Song. Ja, genau, ich meine, Sprechen ist ja auch eine Art von Musik. Ne, geht's. Hm, hm, ne. Na gut. Ne, angewidert. Ne, ne, ne. Aber das war wirklich so Zwei Tage vorm Abgabe des Jingles,
Deadline, drang gedacht,
fuck, ich muss ...
Mit der Nacht.
Scheiße, das war übermorgen.
Schatz, was ist los?
Fuck.
Warum redest du in dieser Lautstärke?
Ich habe komplett vergessen, dass übermorgen der Abgabetermin ist für den Domino-Day-Jingle. Es ist mitten in der Nacht, es ist mitten in der Nacht. Ich weiß nicht, warum du so... Mann, ich muss das noch alles ausarbeiten. So schrecken. Ich würde so schrecken, wenn jemand in der Mitte in der Nacht lautstark sagen würde. Ach man, ey. Es gibt tatsächlich einen ganz, ganz tollen Instagram-Account von jemandem, der im Schlaf redet. Oh je. Und der filmt sich immer nachts. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Das kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen, weil es ist einfach grossartig, auch mit euch auf jeden Fall an. Es ist toll. Ich habe Angst vor schlafenden, vor redenden Schläfern. Weißt du, man sagt dann eher die Wahrheit? Die sagen Dinge, die man nicht zurückgeht. Kinder, Betrunkene und Schlafwandler sagen immer die Wahrheit. Low key habe ich Angst vor Betrunkenen und vor Schlafenden. Weil die sagen gleich Dinge, mit denen sie mich verletzen, die sie nicht zurücknehmen können. Ich habe wirklich die Angst, das ist unironisch, Angst vor Schlafwandlern.
Gut, aber wie würde das konkret aussehen?
Also angenommen, du kannst nachts nicht schlafen oder was, neben dir schläft jemand, der mal dann...
So ein Arschloch.
Stefan, du Arschloch, ey.
Du kannst nichts, du wirst nie was zu was bringen.
Ähm, Schatz, Schatz, Schatz fünf. Weißt du, was du gerade geträumt hast? Sorry, sorry, sorry. Weißt du, was du gerade geträumt hast jetzt? Baby, Baby, Baby Girl. Was ist Sweet Baby?
Darling, wovon hast du gerade geträumt, weißt du das noch?
Honey, ich hab ... Ich weiss nicht, was ist denn los, warum weckst du mich denn?
Nee, ich hab ... Du hast so komisch ... Du hast so komisch, als hättest du vergessen zu atmen, deswegen hab ich ... Sweetheart, hab ich dich geweckt.
Vergessen zu atmen?
Nee, also ... Papa Bear, sowas mache ich doch nicht.
Sweetie, du hast was gesagt im Schlaf.
Das hat mich ein bisschen getroffen, verletzt.
Du weisst, das ist mein Triggerpoint, wenn mich jemand als Arschloch, unerfolgliches Arschloch bezeichnet.
Das triggert mich irgendwie. Was, das habe ich gesagt im Schlaf? Das triggert mich irgendwie. Genau das konkret, weißt du, das trifft mich halt besonders, wenn mich jemand so konkret beleidigt. Ich weiss, es ist mega weird und so, aber nee, es ist genau das, was mich triggert. Honey Bunny, das tut mir leid, es war doch nicht mein Ernst, es ist im Schlaf, das sagt man nur so. Okay. Es tut mir leid, du weisst, ich verehre deine Arbeit, ich bin ein grosser Fan. Das hast du noch nicht gelesen, das Buch. Ich habe viel Gutes darüber gehört. Warum willst du es nicht einfach lesen? Ich lese nicht so gerne diese Art von Büchern. Wie, das heisst die Art von Büchern, das sind immer nur ein Roman. Naja, das ist ja so diese Detektiv-Spionage im alten England, das ist einfach nicht, ich lese eher moderne Sachen. Ich lese eher moderne Sachen im Hier und Jetzt. Ja, wow. Guck mal, das Buch, mit dem du eingeschlafen bist, Die Bibel. Das ist ein Klassiker. Du kannst dich doch jetzt nicht mit der Bibel vergleichen. Das meine ich jetzt gar nicht, du hast wohl nur deine Lüge Du bist ein guter Autor, aber die Bibel ist etwas da teilweise wirklich für Twists. Das ist so feinkonstruiert. Nee, nee, ich sag nichts. Erst denkt man, der ist tot und dann aber nach drei Tagen ist er nicht tot. Alter, ich spoil nicht, ich spoil nicht. Nee, nee, ich habe nicht gesagt, was passiert. Er lebt doch.
So, ich lege mich jetzt noch mal schlafen, okay?
Gute Nacht.
Kennst du das, dass wenn man... Kannst du schreiben.
Schatz, du kannst doch nicht eingeschlafen sein.
Nee, du kannst unmöglich schon geschlafen haben.
Du hast gesagt, du kannst nicht schreiben. Ich versuche nur zu schlafen. Du hast auch nicht geschlafen. Ich hab geschlafen. Sag mal, schläfst du eigentlich überhaupt, wenn du im Schlaf sprichst? Oder sagst du einfach Dinge, die du mir einfach vom Herzen werden willst? Was? Das ist mitten in der Nacht. Vom Herzen werden willst? Ich bin echt kein guter Autor. Und er konnte nie wieder schlafen. Und er konnte weder schreiben noch schlafen. Naja, aber nachts bin ich auch, glaube ich, eher ein abweisender Typ. Wow. Das ist wirklich mal so, Herr Tietze, wo würden Sie Ihre größte Schwäche sehen? Im Im Schlaf bin ich ein Arschloch. Wie meinst du? Jeder schläft für sich allein. Am Ende schläft jeder für sich allein. Das ist Ihre grösste Schwäche, Sie sind im Schlaf etwas abweisend, während Sie schlafen. Ja, das kann man schon sagen. Ich bin rundum ein perfekter Mensch. Können wir Sie nicht nehmen, Herr Tietze, so funktioniert das nicht. Hier bei Kopenrad und Wiese können wir sie so nicht nehmen. Wieso, weil der die ganze Zeit geschlafen wird, oder was? Ne, das geht nicht, das ist ein schlechter Mensch. Sie können nicht hier Tiefkühltorten den ganzen Tag machen. Weil ich bin ja wach, wenn ich zur Arbeit komme. Wenn wir wissen, dass sie abweisend sind im Schlaf. Herr Koppenrath, Herr Wiese. Ja. Herr Wiese? Ja, die Gespräche macht eher mein Kollege. Sie haben sich bislang zurückgehalten. Ich bin eher der Introvertierte von uns beiden. Herr Kopenward, Herr Wiese, ich schlafe ja hier nicht. Ich habe das eher gesagt, weil ich dachte, das ist vielleicht keine Schwäche, die mich jetzt hier beeinträchtigt. Schlaf ist der Mensch, wie er wirklich ist. Das war schon immer unser Credo, das ist unser Motto. Da steht auf jeder Packung Tiefkühltorte steht, der Mensch ist er selbst, wenn er schläft. Jetzt habe ich mich gewundert, ich habe neulich so eine Schwarzwäler Kirschtorte gegessen, köstlich, köstlich. Ja, danke. Aber das wollte ich genau auch in die Marketing-Kommunikationsabteilung mit einbringen, dieser Quote ist mega komisch auf einer Torte. Das ist nun mal das, woran wir glauben.
Das sind Familienunternehmen. Mein Vater,
Cooper Coppenrath,
hat das gelebt.
Tut mir leid.
Das Gemälde da hinten an der Wand, ist das er?
Ja, das ist er, mein alter Vater, der Alte.
Gott hab ihn selig.
Gott hab ihn selig. Wir haben ihn komplett eingefroren.
Weil wir hier in der Fabrik hatten wir noch
diese ganzen Tiefkühl. Ah, es ist so eine Familientradition, dass man sich einfriert. Ja, es ist komplett eingefroren, ja. Herr Wiese redet wieder nicht. Er ist eher der Introvertierte von uns beiden, hat er ja gesagt. Er hat mir bereits etabliert, ja. Ja, es war schwierig. In seinem Testament hat er gesagt, er wollte neben Beyoncé begraben werden. Cooper Coppenrad? Die Cooper. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ich meine, er ist tot und natürlich die Wünsche des Toten. Sie ist nicht tot, aber wir wissen jetzt auch nicht genau, ob wir im Moment ihres Ablebens an ihre Familie herantreten können und sagen, Entschuldigung, Herr Beyoncé, Herr Knowles, Frau Knowles, unser tiefstes Beileid.
Danke.
Wir haben Sie verloren in diesem tragischen Unglück in Frankfurt. Das tut uns so leid. Die ganze Stadt ist domioartig zusammengefallen. Wir haben eine Tiefkühltorte für Sie mitgebracht. Okay. Also meine tiefstes Beileid. Sie hat wirklich keinen Hunger eigentlich. Eine Sache, ich weiss, Sie sind gerade in tiefer Trauer, aber mein Vater, Cooper Coppenrath, hat in seinem Testament geschrieben, dass er gerne neben ihrer Tochter Beyoncé beerdigt werden würde. Ich weiss, die Beerdigung steht noch an, aber wir haben ihn eingefroren und wir haben ihn mitgebracht. Wäre es möglich, dass er bei der Beerdigung mit in das Grab ihrer Tochter ging? Nee, weil ihr exklusiver Wunsch ist, alleine beerdigt zu werden. Ja, aber er ist ja als Erster gestorben. Ach so, okay, ja gut, dann … Ja? Ja, ich meine, das ist die Regel. Okay, das ist nett, vielen Dank. Wer dazu erster bekommt seinen Willen. Okay, wir dachten, wir fahren ganz umsonst hierher nach L.A. Nee, wir respektieren den Wunsch. Und außerdem ist es eine grosse Ehre, mit dem grossen Cooper Coppenrath begraben zu werden. Das freut mich, danke. Gut, dann haben wir das. Wir packen auch noch einen anderen jemanden rein. Vielleicht finden wir noch, wir graben Elvis aus und schmeißen ihn auch noch in das. Das muss doch nicht rein. Nein, aber das ist das Mindeste, was wir tun können. Ja gut, okay, dann machen wir es so. Ja okay, komm. Okay, alles klar, noch mein Beileid noch mal. Nein, danke, nein, danke, an ihn. Ja. In der Familie, die Mr. Knowles. Ja, glaube ich auch. Weiß ich nicht. Es gibt ja Pete Davidson, der mittlerweile überall in der High Society unterwegs ist, hat ja auch erzählt, wie es war, bei Kanye West und Beyoncé Knowles zu Hause zu sein. Und er meinte, die macht ganz tollen Bananen-Pudding. Ich glaube, war das die? Ich glaube nicht, dass die... Nee. Nee, nee, Kim Kardashian. Wie gesagt, deswegen müsst ihr aufhören, mit uns zu zitieren auf Partys. Frau Knowles, wir haben uns geirrt, es war Kim Kardashian. Entschuldigung. Aber jetzt haben wir die beiden schon in ein Grab geworfen. Wir müssten das nochmal aufmachen. Ich habe die genommen und reingeworfen. Es tut mir so, es ist mir so unangenehm. Ach, das ist ja so. Es ist mir so unangenehm. Und Herrn Wiese auch. Der hat noch nie gesagt. Der ist eher der Introieren von uns beiden. Es tut mir so leid, aber wir müssten noch mal ihn da rausholen. Okay, ja komm. Elvis auch? Elvis lassen wir drin. Dann machen wir jetzt kein Riesending draus. Kim Kardashian war, sorry. Und er meinte, dass Kim Kardashian richtig guten Bananenpudding macht. Hätte man das gedacht? Nein. Weiß ich nicht, aber in dem Moment dachte ich mir, geil, ich will auch irgendwie, dass Leute bei mir zu Besuch sind und sagen, der Flöntchen will, der hat ja unendlich viele Talente, aber auch noch macht er einen unglaublich guten Bananenpudding. Und ich hab mir echt überlegt, ich mach jetzt Bananenpudding, weil wie geil ist das denn? Gemeine Unterstellung, aber ich glaube nicht, dass du ein guter Gastgeber bist.
Und guck mal, jetzt hast du den Punkt getroffen, wo ich richtig hart getroffen werde. Jetzt hast du meine Schwachstelle getroffen. Bei unerfolgliches Arschloch hast du mich getroffen. Das war meine persönliche Schachtel. Bei mir war ein schlechter Gastgeber. Wir sind hier völlig offen, alle unsere Schwachstellen sind offen. Ich meine, weil du so konkret weißt, was du willst, im positivsten Sinne. Und ich glaube nicht, dass du Dinge hast, wie wenn ich jetzt sage, jetzt habe ich mir ein Bauer auf ein Stück Salami. Nicht, dass du das hast. Nee, du hast recht. Ich bin ein schlechter Gastgeber, auch weil ich mit vielen Dingen keinen Kontakt habe, wie zum Beispiel Alkohol. Genau, Alkohol. Ich habe keinerlei Alkohol.
Und ich müsste wirklich, wenn ich wüsste, jemand kommt so abends zum Essen, würde ich willkürlich verschiedene Liköre und Dinge kaufen. Eierlikör. Du hast kein Bier, aber Eierlikör besorgt. Einerseits, ich wäre gern ein guter Gastgeber, und zwar nur für diesen einen Moment. Wenn das Essen schon so fertig ist, Dessert, und man redet noch so und dann sagt man noch so, so, wer hat jetzt noch Lust auf einen schönen Grapper? Grapper, okay. Und ich will nur diesen Moment, diesen so, also dieses, es ist eigentlich schon abgeschlossen. Ich habe noch was vorbereitet, ich habe noch eine kleine Brasche. Genau, ich habe noch, so, und wer will jetzt noch einen kleinen Rahmen zutaten? Oh, na klar. So, komm, ich mache die Flasche auf. Da sage ich nicht nein. Das ist für mich der eigentliche Gastgeber. Nicht das Essen, das ist ja alles klar, sondern eher dieses, so. Ja, dieses eine zurückgehalten. Markus, ich habe es dir ja erzählt. Herr Bayer letztens ein bisschen hatte Probleme am Zoll. Und ich sag mal so, der Zollbeamte hat mir als kleine Wiedergutmachung für die ganzen Probleme, die es gab, hat er mir eine schöne Kiste kubanische Zigarren mitgegeben.
Ach nein. Und ich würde sagen, wenn ihr Lust habt, Renate, Renate, wenn ihr Lust habt, dann machen wir die doch mal auf.
Oder extra für euch, ich habe die extra aufgehoben.
Komm, ich hole sie mal aus dem Arbeitszimmer und dann machen wir uns mal eine schöne Zigarre an. Echte Kubano, sage ich mal. Echte Kubano, ja. Okay, alles klar. Alles klar für Valentin. Dann ist er ausgewandert. Aber sowas würde ich gerne machen. Irritierenderweise nach Kuba.
Ich glaube, ich werde den ganzen Abend nervös, weil ich nur auf diesen Moment warte, auf diesen Auf-Oberschenkel-Hau-Moment, dieses so, dieses jetzt sind wir unter uns, jetzt fallen alle Protokoll.
Hüllen.
So, jetzt aber mal.
Und dann versprichst du dich beim Wort Grappa und dann hört man so, wie ins Arbeitszimmer gehst und dich erschießt.
Fuck!
Wer hat jetzt noch Lust auf einen schönen Grappo? Äh, ach, du meinst Grappa, ja doch, hätte ich schon Lust drauf, wäre schon cool. Schrotpinnte, Jesus Christ, da will aber jemand auf Nummer sicher sicher gehen. Du bist ein guter Gastgeber, hast du Tipps? Also was sind gute Tipps? Also so feuchte Tücher oder so? Alles da haben. Feuchte Tücher? Mülleimer am Klo. Mülleimer auf dem Klo, feuchte Tücher am Tisch? Mülleimer am Tisch, feuchte Tücher am Klo. Okay. Dann so kleine Handtücher neben dem Waschbecken. Oh, okay. Kleine, nasse Handtücher. Alles muss nass sein generell. Alles muss nass, nasse Gabeln, warme Messer, alles muss schön frisch nass sein, dass der Gast das wirklich das Gefühl hat, oh, das Handtuch zerrift. Viel Spaß dabei, die Hände in den Augen zu bekommen. Dann schmeißt jemand Wein um, kein Problem, ich habe es, nimmt dieses klatschnasse Handtuch und wisch den Wein noch so über den ganzen Tisch. Oh, oh, Entschuldigung. Jetzt ist alles auf deine weisse Blose gekommen. Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, alles nass hier. Sorry. Nee, ich habe gern, ich habe gern gute Getränke und darin bin ich, glaube ich, ein guter Gastgeber. Hast du denn auch feine, nicht alkoholische Getränke? Ich denke jetzt an sowas wie Ginger Ale, Schweppes, Kiba, ja sowas. Hast du so eine Bar? Nee, ich weiß nicht, wessen Bit es ist, aber man vergisst ja bei Abenden, wo man dann trinkt, Alkohol trinkt, vergisst man ja so ein bisschen, was Menschen normalerweise trinken. Sowas wie Wasser hat man dann vielleicht noch. Ja, aber Apfelschorle, man hat dann nur so weirde Sachen.
So eine Fassbrause.
Ja, genau. Wie heissen diese bitteren kleinen roten ... Weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich nicht. Bittere kleine roten ...
Anekdotenalarm.
Nee, diese ...
Aber du verstehst, man versucht vor allem auch, Leute, die nicht trinken, in in so eine Bierecke oder so eine alkoholische Ecke zu lotsen. Ja, ja. Ich meine, so etwas wie Fassbrause. Man will den Leuten dann auch wie so eine Bierflasche. Man hält das nicht aus, dass man, und man trinkt ja selber, den ganzen Tag trinkt man aus einem fucking Glas oder aus einer Flasche Wasser. Und das ist völlig okay. Ist doch völlig okay. Aber abends in so einem Trinkrahmen muss man denen so eine Bierflasche mit Fassbrause oder ein alkoholfreies Bier in die Hand drücken. Und das verstehe ich immer nicht. Ja, es fällt irgendwie aus dem Rahmen. Alle haben so einen schönen Weinglas oder so eine Sektflöte. Und einer hat halt so seinen Fruchthut auf mit so Strohhalmen und saugt da schön seinen Fruchtsaft raus. Das fällt auf. Trinkpäckchen. Ein schönes Trinkpäckchen, ja. Capri-Sonne. Kannst du das zumindest in Weinglas umfüllen. Capri-Sonne! Ich habe extra meinen Capri-Sonne-Dragonfruit dabei. Kann ich die, vielleicht ich kann sie auch umfüllen. Und dann spritzt man das so aus ganz übertrieben großer Distanz. In so ein tolles Weinglas. Mit so einem viel zu starken Strahl. Okay. Ja, Prost. Deswegen zum Beispiel, was ich zum Beispiel empfehle, als nicht alkoholisches Getränk, Vanilla Coke. Ist was Edles, ist was Feines, aber kann man auch gut wegtrinken so. Ich liebe Vanilla Coke, ich liebe Cherry Coke, ich liebe Vanilla Cherry Coke. Oh ja.
Gibt es ein Getränk, das man einfach, ich mische einfach alles? Also dass sich Sprite, Sprite, Cherry, Vanilla, Coke, alles zusammen einfach?
Ja. Gibt's ein Getränk, dass man einfach, ich mische einfach alles? Also dass sich Sprite, Cherry, Vanilla, Coke, alles zusammen einfach? Einfach alles zusammen mischen. Einfach sagen, das Getränk heißt Fuck It. Einfach so, ich nehme nochmal eine grosse Fuck It, bitte. Das Getränk heißt Everything, Everywhere, All at Once. Einfach alles drin. All at once, lieben wir. Ab wann hört ein Gericht auf, ein Gericht zu sein? Also ab wann ist zu viel?
Dass du einfach sagst, du machst jetzt eine Lasagne mit Pizzaschichten und Tortellini mit drin und so, und wann sagt man, das ist nichts mehr, das ist zu viel. Das kann man nicht mehr abgrenzen von anderen Gerichten. Das ist einfach zu viel. Ich glaube, die erste Lasagne war das schon. Die Lasagne ist schon zu viel. Als es zum ersten Mal am Tisch kam, gab es so ein Thema. Es doppelt sich ja irgendwann. Warum nicht nur eine Schicht? Das ist eine herbe Torte. Okay, andere Meinungen? Haben noch andere Meinungen zu meinem Gericht? Ich habe nicht darum gebeten, jetzt ein Q&A zu machen. Ich wollte jetzt nicht eure Bewertungen bekommen okay. Wo wir gerade dabei sind, okay, es ist eine herbe Torte, es doppelt sich, hat noch jemand Meinung zu meinem Gericht? Das ist pervers. Okay, alles klar. Das ist zu viel auf einmal. Ich habe mich eingeladen, um ein guter Gastgeber zu sein. Es sind vier verschiedene Käsesorten, alle zusammengebrutzelt. Das ist eine Abscheulichkeit, was du uns hier vorsetzt. Ich finde es köstlich, okay? Und Marianne magst du auch. Richtig, Marianne?
Naja, ich kann's nur, wenn ich nicht hinguck.
Ich weiss das alles nicht. Ich weiss das alles nicht.
Wie lange geht das schon? Wie lange habt ihr schon eure kleine Lästereirunde gegen mich?
Wir wären Freunde. Jetzt kommt ihr ihr an? Naja, ich sag mal so, seit dem Käse Fondue fangen wir an zu reden. Du hast einfach einen riesigen Käse auf die Heizung gestellt. Es ist ein geschmolzener Käse. Es ist ein riesengeschmolzener Käse. Das ist doch keine Mahlzeit. Jeder mag Käse, stütt ein Brot da rein. Das ist doch keine Mahlzeit. Das ist doch fantastisch. Das war einfach ein Mehr an Käse. Die Nachwelt wird davon sprechen. Ich, Mr. Fondue Lasagne, der Doppelnamen, auf den ich stolz bin, wird in die Nachwelt getragen. Und ihr werdet euch alle schämen für eure Rezensionen. Ich hasse dich, Alforno. Der grosse Lasagnenkrieg eigentlich.
Ich meine, irgendjemand hat doch die alle erfunden, oder? Gab es so eine Art italienischen Mozart, der all diese geilen Gerichte erfunden hat und hat gekämpft gegen den anderen, gegen Senior Colton Cannelloni, der sich halt so halbgeil ... Luigi Lasagno. Gegen Cabaret Di Canoli, der sich halt so nicht richtig durchgesetzt hat. Sowas wie Cannelloni, die sind geil, aber sind nicht auf einer Stufe von Lasagne oder Pasta da Pezza. Es ist nicht auf der gleichen Ebene. Ich musste, einer der ersten Wörter, die man lernt, wenn man Italienisch lernt mit Duolingo, ist übrigens Stoffata für Schmorbraten. So irritierend, wie früh das Wort für Schmorbraten. Es kam deutlich.
Hallo, tschüss, Schmorbraten. So irritierend, wie früh das Wort für Schmorbraten.
Es kam deutlich, es kam deutlich.
Hallo, tschüss, Schmorbraten.
Schmorbraten, smörbrödet, smörbrödet, Apfel kam so weit hinter Schmorbraten.
Ja, da merkt man die Prioritätensetzung als Landes.
Du lernst ja nicht nur die Vokabeln, sondern auch die Kultur.
Und du meinst einfach Apfel, ach, brauchst du nie. Schmorbraten. Schmorbraten.
Italienisch? Was heißt das? Stoffata? Stoffata.
Stoffata. Si.
Moment mal, das war nicht der Schwedisch-Kurs. Ich habe das alles Schwedisch ausgeschwommen.
Stoffata. Stoffata. Stoffata. Buongiorno.
Okay. Pizze. Pizze. Stoffata. Kann, es ist bestimmt bei jemandem passiert. Tiramisu Cheatet euch diese Woche mal durch mit Fake-Sprachen, ihr müsst nicht die Sprache lernen. Es reicht, wenn ihr einfach selbstbewusst so tut, als könntet ihr die Sprache. Redet auf Leute ein. Einfach den Klang, die Melodie. Ist auch toll, wenn ihr aus Gesprächen rauskommen wollt, einfach nur wieder Sprache sprechen. Ich glaube, es funktioniert auch, wenn du einem echten Schweden gegenüberstehst und einfach nur Kauderwelt-Schwedisch redest und dabei die richtigen Mimik und Gestik das übertragt, was du sagen möchtest. Klar, wenn die Schweden für eins bekannt sind, dann die überbordende theatralische Mimik und Gestik. Stuppart der Stökelme. Die Finger zusammen gehen in die Höhe. Das ist Schweden für mich, so lieben wir es und ich wünsche euch. Lernt Sprachen. Eine schöne Woche, lernt Sprachen. Und setzt euch mal ganz bewusst hin. Schaut euch mal, wie viele Stühle habt ihr in eurer Wohnung, wie viele verschiedene Stühle. Und dann setzt euch mal auf einen Stuhl und dann setzt euch auf den anderen Stuhl und dann überlegt mal, was ist der Unterschied? Was macht das mit euch? Die These, ihr sitzt häufig auf dem gleichen Stuhl. Genau. Wechselt mal die Perspektive. Setzt euch mal auf den anderen Stuhl, schaut mal, hat der Lehnen? Oh, was macht das mit mir? Plötzlich hat der Stuhl Lehnen, fühle ich mich anders, bin ich ein anderer Mensch? Ja, genau, macht das oder habt einfach eine schöne Woche. Ja, also kann ich mich, der König sitzt ja auch auf dem Thron, wie der Stuhl so der Mensch. Stühle machen Leute. Ja. Wohingegen auf einem Hocker, nehmt den Stuhl mal vorne rum, macht mal den Vertretungslehrer. Sowas. Und dann setzt euch mal hin, was macht das, setzt euch mal aufrecht hin. Was macht das mit euch, was macht mit eurer Hose. Ja, was macht das mit eurer Hose, was macht das mit deinen Armen, redet ihr anders auf anderen Stühlen, ja, setzt euch mal hin und fühlt das mal so richtig aus.
Setzt euch mal auf den Boden, wenn eure eigene Wohnung auf den Boden sitzt.
Ah, auf den Boden, Schneidersitz, auf dem Teppich, mir fühlt sich das an. Oder wenn ihr Schneidersitz nicht könnt? Bauch, Bauch, legt euch mal auf dem Rücken, legt euch mal auf dem Rücken und versucht euch mal so oft wie es geht nach links zu drehen. Wie oft könnt ihr euch in eurer Wohnung, schaut mal, welche Route müsstet ihr in eurer Wohnung beschreiten, dass ihr euch so oft wie es geht auf dem Boden rumrollen könnt? Guckt mal, vielleicht ist die Antwort intuitiv, vielleicht nicht. Könnt ihr euch von einem Zimmer ins andere rollen, um sozusagen noch mehr Meter und mehr Rollen gut zu machen? Das sind alles tolle Vorschläge für Valentin. Ich weiß nicht, aber sei nicht sauer, wenn sie es nicht machen.
Sei nicht enttäuscht, weil du bist immer so enttäuscht, wenn da nichts kommt.
Ja, aber probiert es zumindest mal.
Ja, probiert es.
Legt euch mal draußen hin, setzt euch mal auf den Stein hoch.
Was ist das denn?
Baumstumpf.
Der Elternabend ist ein bisschen abgedriftet.
Danke an den Vater von Maximilian, der hier war.
Danke an euch, liebe Podcast-Ufer-Community, dass ihr den Stuhl einfach zurückstellen könntet. Das war der, genau. Ich glaube, wir haben alles besprochen. Wenn jeder noch so ein, zwei Sachen Müll mitnimmt, sind wir hier auch ganz schnell durch. Sehr viel Müll. Wenn ich mich so umschaue, ist dann doch ein bisschen ein paar Krümel. Wenn jeder zwei so Hanuta-Päckchen
wieder einstecken kann, ich verstehe auch nicht, wie sich das etabliert hat. Wenn jeder zwei so zwei Arme voll mitnimmt an Müll. Irgendwie hat sich das etabliert, das alles einfach wütend in den Raum schmeissen, das haben wir nicht ganz verstanden. Ja, ist egal. Wenn die Mutter von Johanna hat irgendwie da am Anfang mal angefangen und dann sind alle so ein bisschen mitgezogen. Klar, irgendwann ist das auch so ein Gruppenzwang, Peer-Pressure. Wir wollten es nicht extra ansprechen, aber jetzt ist es dann doch ein Thema geworden. Jetzt haben wir es aber auch geklärt, da müssen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter darauf eingehen. Schön, dass ihr da wart. Ich glaube, es war gut, dass wir uns mal so ausgesprochen haben. Deswegen dann nächste Woche wieder ein normales Intro, ne? Ja, bis dahin macht's gut. Wir heben ab. Wer ist dafür für Abheben? Mal Handzeichen bitte. Okay, drei.
Drei, vier, ah Bettina, ist das ein Handzeichen?
Ihr kratzt ja am Kopf.
Ja, das ist ein Handzeichen.
Ah, okay, alles klar.
Nee, dann haben wir die Mehrheit fürs Abheben, dann würde ich sagen, letzter Tagespunkt der Ordnung, Abheben.
Abheben.
It was the worst bird production, I guess.